good morning John my name is dr.
Lawrence turtleman Hank
graciously handed the reins over to me
for the last day of pizza miss which is
a huge honor I really loved watching
pizza miss over the last couple of weeks
huh videos the reunions the almond
orchards the reviews but me dr. turtle
Minh I'm here to talk to you today about
taxonomical oddity see all organisms on
earth are related to each other we can
trace that the way that scientists did
for hundreds of years using the
morphology of organisms and we could
also trace it using genetics like it's
easy to see how a tiger and a lion are
related to each other and it's easy to
see how a wolf and a fox would be
related to each other but you can also
kind of tell that oh lion and a wolf are
more related to each other than they
would be to say I don't know like a
sheep or a turtle man if we look into
the fossil record we can find the common
ancestor of dogs and cats
it's the Mia Sid a sort of weird proto
carnivore bear dog cat thing when we
learned about organisms and their
relationship to each other in school we
learned about it through the lens of
taxonomy every category in taxonomy
going all the way from domain down to
species is called a taxon and every
taxon is built to contain multiple taxa
so in the order carnivora we have all
kinds of families we have the canines
and the feelings we also have the
persons and the pinnipeds in the
mustelid and each of those families
there are multiple general entity to
those Venus's there are a bunch of
different species these weird
taxonomical Islands that I want to talk
to you about today you might find
yourself with an order that only has one
family in it that only has one genus in
it that only has one species in it
that'll be like having only one
carnivore currently existing on the
planet is this a thing that could even
happen as far as I can tell this is only
the case for two terrestrial vertebrates
we have order to bulid in tada
containing just the one species the
aardvark aardvarks are extremely
successful in Rome all across Africa but
nevertheless all of their ancestors have
gone extinct and we have order a pista
coma for maize which contains just one
species the Watson Watson is a South
American bird that's really weird which
you can tell by looking at it look look
at that thing but I do also want to talk
about two runners up here a non
terrestrial vertebrate that has two
species in its order the coelacanth
before me we once thought that the
coelacanths have been extinct for 66
million years until we found one in 1938
and then we later found another species
and finally we also have order Rinku
sofia which contains the two species of
tuatara now we
very nearly lived in a world with only
one species of tuatara but a second
species was found living on only one
island off the coast of New Zealand to
atera of course do look a lot like
modern lizards but in fact their last
shared ancestor with the modern lizards
and snakes was over a hundred and fifty
million years ago you might be asking
hey dr. turtle and if they're so
different from lizards and snakes give
me an example of one of those
differences
well tuatara like to bite and chew on
stuff but instead of using teeth to do
that they just grow their bones up
through their gums now you might think
that I'm done here that I told you all
the weirdest taxonomic islands what's
the species that really takes the cake
here is not an animal alone in its order
it's a plant alone in its division the
gingko tree shares a kingdom which is
the second largest of all of the taxa
with all plants and then after that it
is all on its own the only species and
its division and remarkably now that you
humans have come to enjoy them so much
they've been planted all over the world
and spread out from their original
location in Asia the ginkgo trees have
been welcomed into the Anthropocene a
lovely species stretching back through
time alone on one of the most isolated
of taxonomic islands oh thank you dr.
turtleman that was that was a lovely
presentation you're great and thank you
to everyone for hanging out this pizza
miss it's been a great time I can't
believe that it's already over Alice
I'll see you last time if you want to
get this year's pizza miss stuff make it
for two weeks and then never again so if
you go to dftba.com slash pizza miss or
click on the end screen here you can get
some of that stuff thanks for joining us
this pizza miss has been a really good
time and John I will see you like normal
on Tuesday